attention shoppers even a big box store
has to close and it's about that time
you know when pandora closed her famous
box there was only one thing left inside
hope i wonder what will be left inside
of this box
could it be grace i hope not
if you're grace's parents please pick
her up at customer service
uh attention cloud 9 shoppers be sure to
stop by grocery for a free sample of
senor cloud salsa
and in pharmacy get yourself a flu shot
available in medium mild
picante and i'm almost positive that was
written down wrong
attention shoppers there's a 40 off sale
in our exercise gear section
which will be closing next week due to
lack of interest over in patio furniture
we're gonna have a look
uh my bad y'all that reaction was very
out of character for me
um normally a very cool guy i have a lot
of
cool sneakers and a very active sex life
uh attention cloud9 shoppers apparently
black friday has begun
from all of us here at cloud9 have a
great purge
attention cloud9 shoppers today is
cloud9's wellness fair where we're
offering vision tests blood pressure
screenings and tips on living your best
healthiest life why go to a doctor where
you can get medical advice from the same
place you get
so all right
i uh i messed up before i'm i'm sorry i
i was listening
but i wasn't really hearing so here's
what we're gonna do tonight
i'm gonna pop open a couple brewskis
we're gonna get ourselves a nice
pie pizza pie not pecan or whatever
and we are gonna watch ourselves a
little movie called
bad boys too and get you through this
breakup thing roomy style
all right that's enough attention cloud
nine employees
i am fine dina did not break up with me
and actually if you want to get real
about it
it was my idea i was trying to be a nice
guy
i got this so if you want to feel bad
for somebody feel bad for dina cause
she's the one
seeing the shrink oh
that was something i shouldn't have said
sorry about that please pretend you
didn't hear that
have a good day
i'm gonna just put these back
attention shoppers cloud9 brand tablets
are half off
the halo fog has a hd display and boasts
a battery life of about 45 minutes
hey i need you to work the register
while tim's in the bathroom no i don't
do registers
look i know that it's really the hip
thing for you millennials to not give a
crap
but it's not true and we're the same age
but please go on it's all hands on deck
so quit your myspacing and get on the
register that's an order
all right let me just finish this
announcement fine but the second you're
done i want you on register three
the second i'm down you can also view
thousands of movies on the halo fall i
will now list some of the movies that
are probably on there
mrs doubtfire silence of the lambs
that one where nicholas cage switches
faces and says he's going to eat a peach
for hours
ooh forrest gump that's a good movie
attention cloud9 shoppers
there is a carbon monoxide leak in the
store
it's the silent killer so you're going
to want to go attention cloud9 shoppers
we have a bit of an emergency
in the middle of something right now
attention employees we need you to
assemble in the front of the store for a
group photo in 10 minutes
and look sharp we haven't we have a
chance to have ceo
neil penderson in our store this is not
a prank neil henderson
as i was saying there's a missing child
his name is kaden he has brown hair he's
eight years old and he's wearing
overalls so uh i guess those two things
group photo
missing kit and then jen nay
dies of what is implied to be aids but
we don't know
and he puts hayley joel osment on a bus
and guess what same bus driver from the
beginning
what are you still doing here you're
supposed to be on the register you said
i could finish the announcement yeah
that was ten minutes ago
it's a very long announcement next up
apollo 13.
i see what you're doing here in this
film tom hanks is a space man whose life
is saved by a bunch of nerds
attention shoppers cloud9 is not
offering breast exams as part of our
wellness fair we have not hired someone
to do that
and if we had it would not be a teenage
boy in a 21 pilots t-shirt
shop safe attention cloud9 shoppers this
weekend is mother's day
i don't know your mother but given what
women have gone through this past year i
think it's pretty safe to say
she needs this attention cloud9 shoppers
i do not have an announcement but as
long as i am talking i am not listening
so just
gotta keep talking uh save 30 off roach
gel
stop roaches in their tracks except you
can never really stop them can you
they'll just keep
coming and coming invading your mind in
an endless loop are we there yet daddy
sorry son the hell right it lasts
forever
it's buy one get one free on peas and
then there's one where
tom hanks is in the airport the whole
time honestly i checked out on that one
anybody see sully all right
oh i don't feel so hot i got to take a
break y'all
oh if you're done with the announcement
register three could use a hand
see i don't give up neither do i
don't forget about polar express merry
christmas kids
it's a nightmare
attention cloud9 shoppers it's really
coming down out there now i'm not a
licensed meteorologist but i believe the
technical term is snowy af
for anyone stocking up we are limiting
all water purchases to one case per
person and that does include
coconut water watermelon water cucumber
water
aloe water probiotic water and electric
water which is something i just made up
but you probably got all excited about
and if anybody lost a blue hair thingy
please come pick it up at customer
service
well it's mine
and then the volleyball floats away and
weirdly you're sad about it
at least i was attention all remaining
customers
the governor has declared a state of
emergency customers are advised to get
home before conditions worsen
which begs the question what about
employees who also drive cars
and also have families and or video
games to get home too
yeah i checked on that and corporate
would like us to stay until closing so
glenn this is crazy it's really bad out
there
oh i don't know maybe it's starting to
lighten up a bit
no actually it's getting worse uh
they're calling it the snowpack-a-blizz
oh wait nope that's just some guy on
twitter trying to get it going okay well
yeah i'll
try him again oh no no nope glenn no
that's you're still using the intercom
phone
put it down oh phooey the corporate
let's just get out of here
you heard the man go go hey before you
go can you unlock the razor case
i don't know why you guys lock up the
razor blades
they're actually one of the most
shoplifted items high ticket and easy to
pocket
people also steal name brand detergent
condoms baby formula
you wouldn't think it but they sell it
and buy heroin pretty grim anyway
happy to help
well jonah please report to patio
immediately
i repeat jonah to patio immediately
oh okay i'm on my way
make sure that you actually are
i just said i am yes but sometimes you
say you're gonna do things and then you
don't
why don't we have this discussion in
person given that you just started
working here
what is going on maybe you shouldn't
tell me how to do my job
or maybe you should leave the intercom
open for more important announcements
no you guys go wild i never want this to
end
i am your supervisor don't think you
know this job better than me just
because you did well on some stupid test
the test doesn't make me think i know
better the test is empirical proof
that i do know better attention cloud9
shoppers dildos
are on sale for 69 cents in aisle 69.
hey
bozo we're using the intercom get off
why don't you take your own advice
howard stern for president hey i need
that
a penis penis penis can't figalito's
escape
actually kid that's a lot more
insightful than anything jonas got to
say today
our manager seems to think i'm very
insightful yes that's because you're a
little ass-kissing
face
have a heavenly day
you